I want to talk about the movie uh the
Workaholics it's a it's a legendary
movie MH that could have been made mhh
never was made yeah and I and as as a
fan I want to know why uh I feel like
it's almost it's maybe better that we
didn't make it because now the legend is
built up in people's heads like people
have like came to us and like meet and
greets like crying being like I just
wish it the movie I know it's going be
so good it would have been so I bet it
was going to be I mean it was a very dur
wrote a very very funny script we were
very proud of it we were ready to go uh
and then Paramount plus called us what
is right after New Year's yeah they were
like are you guys uh excited about this
New Year's how do you guys feel about uh
Cameo yeah yeah that'd be so good if
they had somebody from Cameo call to
break the news and go Silver Lining
Cameo and we set your rat
yeah was it upsetting the call
obviously cuz we had like our schedule
we were like uh just four or five weeks
out from like production wow like
already rented out space and director
already hired oh yeah oh my God Kyle
neich who's with us on this tour who is
our writer and director who we created
Workaholics with he was going to come
back and direct we got all the other
cast um cleared a bunch of the like
production staff like our key grip and
the grip team was coming back our
electrical guys were coming back the
camera operators wow everything but then
uh
fouchy Dr fouchy had to open his
[__] dude that was weird that fouchy
himself gave us the call yeah I was like
aren't you buzy and he was like actually
no that's uh pretty easy to make all
this stuff up on this it was Co related
yeah no it wasn't really it was I wish
no no it was not what to do i' just like
to talk
about it was like a comedic take me um
yeah it had nothing to do with um fouchy
or Co it had to do with uh new Global
mandate that Paramount plus was leaning
into because they think that the bigger
they go the more automatic the hits are
so good luck with that yeah so
essentially we were like kind of in the
gray area of were they going to get the
bang for their book like uh we're not
like $100 million property so and since
they're trying to be more International
they said that we didn't have the
international appeal we also don't want
to make a movie for $5 million right
like we want to make something that like
serves our audience gives them a big
adventure something that's like that's
movie worthy you know what I mean and uh
we did seven seasons of the show it was
like you know because at first when they
came to us and they asked us to do a
movie for $5 million we were like well
no essentially that's just we're kind of
doing the show again and I know $5
million to people that don't know how to
make movies that seems like a ton of
money Mariachi was made for 10 grand but
that's true that is true that is true
never seen it 1992 yeah years ago Robert
R big director launched his career heard
Spy
Kids Shark Boy and Lava Girl yeah no
doubt bangers all bangers anyway
talented guy yeah yeah yeah yeah so
essentially uh we said no and then they
came back to us and gave us a real
budget that we were really excited about
we wrote a script and it was we we were
like that we're kind of walking the the
tight RPP of is this going to be too
expensive or not and we were like
willing to take some things back and
like maybe take some set pieces back but
they never even had that conversation
they were just like very funny guys all
right see in a few weeks when we start
production wow yeah wow wow wow wow it
needed about a third act and I had it
all lined up we were we were going to
make some Chang do they own the property
right I mean do they for sure do they
the script though you can't shop it
around anywhere else so uh I mean I
don't know who gives a [__] or to get
two in the legally um but they did give
us the option to take it somewhere
because why wouldn't they want to make
money off of somebody else spending the
money to pay for it right because it
would always revert back to Paramount at
some point and everyone else was like
why would he pay for this movie to be
made to only have it for 24 months right
like doesn't make sense business wise I
saw yeah yeah yeah so it all ended up as
a big pile of
dong that's why we started the strike
yeah
yep enough we've had it yeah I called
Fran
pressure it just has to stop let's
mobilize she's a Fran yeah yeah yeah um
get in there sweetie the boys are cute
right you know we her we I'm not here
for this I just want I want to play game
play game though yeah so can I play a
game I would love to I'm a game guy do a
voice let's let's hear the rul
first you want to play game